You look at that side,
and I'll look at this side.
OK, sounds good.
What was that?
alligator.
Oh, it's a big
son-of-a-bitch, ain't it?
This is not good.
This is where
we're going to start.
We need specialty stuff
for this order, man.
But you don't find it
laying on the shore.
It's a stump.
NARRATOR: The Swampman's
looking for specialty
wood, ornamental pieces
for the bar tops.
You ready?
Oh, yeah, I'm ready.
Let's do it.
NARRATOR: But in the swamp,
ain't nothing come easy.
So to get 'em, they'll
have to get a little wet.
We've got to get in the
water, swim with the gators.
Here we go!
NARRATOR: Now, an
old swamp trick
is to use your feet to find
the logs on the river bottom.
Here's one.
And Shelby's a master at it.
Come here, come here.
Put your foot on this.
Right here.
Jump on it.
See it bob?
- I see that.
- Jump on it.
See it?
So it's got to at least
be eight foot long.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
They got a noise them alligators
make that sound like this--
[imitating alligator] When
I hear that damn sound,
it's time to get [bleep] out
of the water, for damn sure.
[bleep]
Come here.
Let me show you something.
See where the alligator's been
laying up there on the bank?
I've never seen
an alligator trail.
See how it's all split tracks?
That's where an
alligator's been laying.
All right, let's go.
Let's see if we can find
anything in that log,
and see if we can pick it up.
NARRATOR: Now when you come
a'knockin' on a gator's front
door, you best hope he ain't
home, because they don't take
kindly to trespassers.
That's the end of it?
Yep.
Pretty long.
Let me get it.
All right.
Ah!
There's a hook on this one--
[nervous laugh]
Where are you at?
Shelby?
[bleep] You scared
the hell out of me!
It might be too
much in the mud.
Well, that's not good.
I went down to get
that log, and Angela
thought an alligator got me.
Spooked the hell out of her.
The Alligator Alley
does that to folks.
NARRATOR: Now, there's an
old expression in the swamp--
You hear that?
Yeah.
NARRATOR: If at first
you don't succeed,
pray them gators stay
away a little longer.
It's quiet out there, man.
It's too quiet.
One thing you don't want to hear
in Alligator Alley is nothing.
[screaming]
A limb got betwixt my toenails
and pulled it backwards.
I've been using my feet
for years to find logs.
[bleep] tear your
damned toenails off.
Is that meat or a worm?
It's part of your dead
skin from when your toe got--
[bleep]
Oh my god!
Oh man!
- Found one.
- Did you?
Found something.
Pick it up and see.
I can't.
It's too big.
It's right here, right
where I'm standing.
Oh, god!
[laughing]
Son of a bitch, you scared
the [bleep] out of me.
That's really neat.
Yeah, that girl's
good, junior.
Man, she's already finding
logs with her feet.
Is it pretty?
Yes, it's pretty.
NARRATOR: Now the
Alley may have gators,
but once you work
your way past them,
it's also got plenty of
prime logs for the picking.
- Oh man.
- Nice!
That's it, junior.
Got a damn load now.
Go back to land now.
Get in.
Man, we found a bunch
of them down here.
We got all the
special wood we need.
I'm close on this order, man.
Let's go, Shelby.